los líderes mundiales no tardaron en
felicitar el nuevo presidente de eeuu
reino unido reafirmar la relación
cercana entre ambos países
son realmente felicito al show y kamala
harris por su logro en su toma de
posesión hoy es algo fantástico para
eeuu es un paso adelante para el país
han pasado por un periodo lleno de
baches y para nosotros y eeuu es un gran
momento es el primer el primer ministro
israelí benjamín netanyahu recordó la
amistad que ya tiene con el ahora
mandatario presidente de bailén usted y
yo hemos tenido una cálida amistad que
se remonta a muchas décadas espero
trabajar con usted para fortalecer aún
más la alianza entre eeuu e israel
el presidente francés emmanuel macrón
hizo referencia al tratado por el clima
aplaudo el regreso de eeuu al acuerdo
climático de parís bienvenido de nuevo
juntos podremos afrontar los desafíos de
nuestro tiempo todos juntos podremos
cambiar la situación climática tomando
medidas para nuestro planeta en américa
latina el mandatario colombiano iván
duque se pronunció
le deseamos
su discurso orientado hacia la unión del
pueblo norteamericano y también
invitando
que en medio de las diferencias se
construyen objetivos comunes
la llegada del demócrata es vista como
el inicio de un nuevo capítulo desde la
otan mientras que el portavoz de la
canciller angela merkel también aseguró
que alemania espera abrir un nuevo
capítulo con bailén